hi everyone um so I'm G I will speak
about some um some classification PRS
and most especially about psych today so
just a bit of background I'm an open
source software Engineers as the
foundations uh at inria which is in
based in Paris and mainly working on
Psychic learns and I'm also a CO
contributor of imbalance learn which is
something that uh we will see today I
mean this one of the topic that uh is an
angle that I will cover
that I will use today to to present some
insight on some
classifications so to give a bit of
background uh in the past I work uh
during my PhD basically I work on
imbalance
classifications uh the idea was to find
coner on M images like the one that is
here and usually you have a PR that is
called like imbalanced PR because you
have many pixel of V cells that are
considered like non coner and some of
them are only coner so you have a ratio
between those two class which are kind
of like U like very different so in that
case you have like
20 pixel that are nonous for one pixel
that is cerous and that make kind of a
challenge basically when you want to
take a this PRS so if you have such Prem
usually when you you want to to start
work uh on that Prem you will start to
look at the lures so you go to the nice
libraries and look at what people are
doing and if you look at specific PRS
you will find article that say oh
actually you have tricks to to manage
that and uh and you have some that are
like more common than others and for
inance one of the thing that very very
very very popular is like sampling so
for instance SM is one of these
methods uh and somehow because they are
well like doing the PHD doing code one
things that you come with is okay maybe
I can do a tools that everybody can use
uh so I was using psych learn at that
time for
my let's say predictive pipelines then I
I decided to basically make um another
libraries which can be uh compatible
with C that allow basically to make
those type of resampling there inside
inside those Pipeline and then you can
just like use those make create a
pipeline put it inside Coss validation
and at the end of the day you are happy
with that uh then because it's good you
start to write articles you go to
conferences and you start to speak about
it um and then like couple of years
later uh because you still I mean I have
the chance to still work on section and
and discuss with people on on on some
other trouble you see that life is not
that simple and if I have to rename
basically the talk of today that would
be more the following which is um
learning from imbalanced data I was
pretty wrong to do all of this but I was
not the only one
so here I will just like take the angle
of the imbalance PR and to State like
have some uh strong uh opinion on that
and then I will show basically a use
case where uh I will show usually what
we do what the state of the art is
telling you to do and on the other side
show like what are the mistake that are
done on this path and how to solve them
and then I will show as well how in C
are like providing new tools basically
to to like to tackle the real Prem the
root of the prems so the first thing is
that after six years I just realize that
there's no Prem with imbalanced data uh
and and the the intuition that you can
have behind is this intution forance
from this article from one of the
contributor of second nwell which is
Christian Ron uh which is you are not
creating magical uh d data out of
nowhere so uh you cannot do like much
more than what you have so like
resampling is actually prob not
something I mean it's not creating so
much informations and the change that
you see is probably com coming from some
something else and is what you need to
understand
so the typical use case here that I will
take I will take a data set which is
adult sensus data set so it has a mix of
categorical and numerical features and I
resample a bit more to have like rare
imbalance case so I have almost 40,000
cases that I have people earning below
50k doll per year and people that are
earning above 50k okay so you have like
a ratio a larger ratio between
both uh so typically if you use like the
Vana let's say uh models from Psy learn
so here I'm taking two type of model and
there's a reason behind it so one is a
linear model and the one is a random for
so it's because I want to use in one
resampling so that will be the linear
model and in the other one that will be
the random FR because I have another
type of forest which is called balance
ROM Forest later uh and we can make a
direct comparison between those those
models so if I run basically cross
rations on those data using the balance
accuracy so I will come again later on
why to use maybe this is not the pay
choices but let's use what people are
using normally then you will get those
type of results so you will get kind of
low score to what you could expect okay
so the one is around 0. 55 one around 65
and what you are seeking is very improve
that
metric so to do that you check the state
of the art you say okay so I can I can
look at what people do and then is where
the reamping come come come into so
smotes will allow you for instance to
resample the data set and over sample
basically the data set before to make
your logistic regs and on the other side
you will have the balance ROM first and
I will just go to the next slide and the
idea of balance R op is that each of the
boot STP will be as well sample such
that you have balance bootstrap for each
of the tree that you you train okay um
and using those methods
you can like fit those models which are
that see basically a bit different data
and at the time of prediction basically
you don't do anything okay so you you
just predict on the on the real data and
if you do that then you see a push of
performance and uh you could call it the
day okay is what you you obtain so you
are very happy with that you are beting
the like the state of the art let's say
and and then you should be happy with
that that is trouble year so
so there is
uh two of them so one is like when we do
the resampling we actually not
checking let's say we don't try to
optimize anything with it so is it like
the best strategy that we can have is it
uh so when we do resample should we
optimize something and this is really
not clear why why we should do that so
we could still make a grid search but
then we'll see this is really like not
the best strategy either and then the
second thing is that because what we'll
see just next you are actually doing
something wrong with the classifier that
could be actually a TR I mean a big
trouble for you so what is this perms is
about calibrations and it comes to if
you try to use basically the probability
estimate that are provided by your
classifier and uh by doing uh Vana so in
those figures what we have is like what
we call reliability
diagram and meaning if Can I Trust
basically the probability that my
classifier is is providing to me and in
the case of the Vania classifiers who
are more as when the classifiers that
say you have 30% of chance that this is
this class actually is not far from the
truth okay and by doing resampling the
only thing that we do is that we are
breaking uh these calibrations and when
the
tell us that you have 30% of chance to
be class one actually this is not the
case because uh the sampling just like
makes the classifier usually
overconfident because we push him
towards telling us there is a coner that
happen and why people are using
resampling at the end is because we have
this ash that say above 50% will declare
you as class one and Below 50 50% you
will be declared at class zero and the
only thing that the reamping is doing is
kind of moving these thresold without
controlling it but moving this frle
towards the decision that we want okay
that optimize basically the metric that
we expect and uh so in this case it mean
that we get spray the prediction that we
want but we already like broke the
probabilities and in the remaining here
it will be just to show you that you can
still fit prob good probalistic
classifiers and then tune the that
shouldn't be the defa at 0.5 and then
you'll get the best of the two
words so what we are currently working
in San and that will be either in the
release of 1.4 that should be in this
month or the next release of 1.5
depending if we the we pass uh the
boundary of the resist manager uh is to
have um what we call a meta estimators
so these estimators will be in charge of
fitting a models and then afterwards
given the metric it will tune the shold
that by default 0.5 but it will move it
to where it optimize the metric that we
want okay so if I look at uh what we
have normally in in in the in the Vania
case we would have a cut off a 0.5 and
for instance here we can see that this
is a circus and we have a low balance
accuracy but then if I do the if I
compute the balance accuracy for all
possible Shel then I will see that I
have a maximum somewhere and I can pick
up this Shel which is 0 Z 4% basically a
probability of 0. 4% and above it I can
say that you will be in that case so
this is like you will earn above 50,000
and below that it will be you earn on
the 50,000 so at the end of the day you
don't change your classifier at all the
only thing that you change is is your
decisions so it's the rug curve if you
compute a rug curve the curve is exactly
the same for the two classifier and the
only thing that you are doing is moving
along that that Ru curve and in ter of
like if you want to understand in term
of decision you really are just
modifying basically the number that you
have inside the confusion Matrix so in
this case we have we did take more cases
that we have above 50k but we start to
be to make more FS positive and uh but
we do a bit less uh forse negatives and
in total basically this is just a
trade-off so here this this classifier
is really intending when you want to go
from probability to actually make
decisions uh so here we just apply the
classifiers on our previous uh programs
where we will use on one side the Vania
logistic RS and the Vania R the press
and just Tunes both both
approach and then we observe that we are
very very close to what the the sampling
is doing I mean almost so for the
logistic regession we are fine and yeah
for the random rest we are still a bit
below the balance ROM forest and here
one would say yeah I mean it's like 15
minutes that you speak and you say that
you should do that but then at the end
it doesn't work better so there's
something that we missed and what we
missed is uh basically we all forgot to
GD search our models and this is
something which is super important and
uh the reason here and we'll see is that
our random Forest is still somehow
overfitting and by changing things and
basically finding a model that's less on
over fit I will show that basically you
go back to the balance random Forest
and when you do the fine tuning the
important things to do and which is not
the def in Cy and that we PR are
intending to change the future so when
you do the G search you should use what
we call a proper scoring worlds so the
barer score the log loss for
classifications and the reason is
because when you go from this purpose
rules to atic rule like balance accuracy
or accuracy you are losing information
and by doing the grid search they you
you might just like Li to your s so for
instance here on the on on those figures
these is the same models and I will see
here that I have a minimum so because I
have the model that overfit after uh a
th leaves uh I cannot see really what
happened here but here I have a minimum
around those 100 or 200 hips and this
you cannot see it when you use the
balance accuracy because what happen is
that when you go to the sh method you
have several models that could be
equivalent but then inside those
equalent model there is PR one which is
actually the best one when you go when
you use a proper Square rules and the
thing to understand as well is that the
proper scoring rooms is just trying to
optimize the the probability
estimations so one is use the right
metric and the second one isier that we
can have is like to understand why we
didn't have as a good random Forest
compared to a balanced random forest and
uh if we look at the figures from the
right we see that we have a kind where
we reach a plateau and actually this is
the effect of the resampling and the
resampling because we have less data our
forest was uh I mean the sampling was
playing as a regularizations it was
allowing us to not get trees that were
overfitting the data while in the case
on the the left because we have like
much more data there's a point that over
a th leaves we were starting to to over
fit so we probably have a much better
model between let's say we have a better
model in 100 Le compared to the to the
model on the right but then if we were
not optimizing uh the number of leaves
then we end up inside the regim where we
over so here if we tune properly the
models and then we pick up the best
maximum number leaves on the log loss so
this is a result that we have before and
we'll see that if you optimize that then
you will just move the model uh up and
in that case you in the same like both
model are uh as good okay but the big
difference here you are you are
basically accounting for the metric that
you optimize I mean you controlling
everything while this is not something
that you are doing doing during the the
the resampling and then there's cases
that the resampling doesn't work and
here you are sure that basically it will
just try to optimize what you're looking
for so now this something as well I mean
this uh this meta ESET is allowing for
something additional which are like very
very interesting for I mean that's like
the measure feature of of that
features uh leveraging something that we
call metadata rooting so and I will come
like EXP with an example what it is uh
we can actually Define business metric
which was not the case in the past so
metadata routing is very useful in that
particular case so let's imagine that
you have a credit card through examples
and the cost that you have is not
anymore a balance accuracy or Precision
or recall let's say that you define
statistically but really like dollars or
Euros uh and then what you want is a
classifier that Maxim your Revenue so
you want to Max I mean decrease the cost
as much as possible or maximize the gain
in this case and usually what you your
business people are interesting about
that not about your balance accuracy
okay so here what we'll show is that you
can use this tun classifier to optimize
the decision thresold using those
business Ming that you define yourself
so in this case we can go around like a
credit FR a credit card fraud examples
where you will have different uh uh
values but the important part is that
the amount that you have here is not a
feature part of your data neither from
your target this is an external thing
that you can have but uh somehow you
want to bring into your models during
the fitting but is not present in your
data or inside the Target or it
shouldn't be part of like let's say the
the the link between this amount and the
Y
potentially and in this case this is
what we call
metadata so here how we want to uh
Define a metric that use these
informations is uh we would like to
define the business metric that will
take y through and Y spread which is us
really what is output the output of your
classifiers and on the other side is
meta informations and this mis matric
here that is defined here is exactly a
multiplication between the confusion
Matrix and the cost Matrix that we we
got and then we should sum everything
and is telling us what is the gain that
we obtain and I in second 104 you will
already be able for sure to have those
business metric so you need to enable
the metadata routings then you can
create a score that take my business
metric and then you just have to mention
that there some new uh some new metadata
which will be a mon and then you will uh
it will Arrow basically in the next
stage to to say to the to the scorers
take this uh information and provide to
the business metric as a parameter okay
so it's what happened here I can call
thiss where I pass my model the data and
the target which are like the free
information that we could could already
do and this additional information about
amount and this amount here will be
dispatched basically to the business
metric then I'm able to compute
scores that take into account this
metadata um then
uh then we have this how can I like play
with the co sensitive learning so it's
to use like the tune Shel
classifiers and the objective metric
here is not anymore the balance accuracy
but this but this business magic and
then at fit time I can pass this
informations a mon which is for the
training this is Theon train and during
the the evaluations I can pass Theon
test and then I will get in in basically
in dollars or in Euros uh what is the
gain to uh by I mean what is the gain of
my
classifier so we can as well use this
inside the cross validation and in that
case what I obtain is exactly these
things okay so uh you get your model
your data and your target you pass the
metadata and you pass the scoring that
you want and in this case that we can
see that the Vana logistic regession
that didn't use the amount to during the
fitting didn't try to optimize that is
much worse than the what you obtain when
you post tune basically a logistic
regression for that specific metric and
in this case this I I would say this is
super important to use whenever you can
a business metric instead of an accuracy
uh or like prediction or recall when it
comes to take a decision because this
usually what uh you marketing people
will
want so as a conclusion here I have a
couple of message which is stop
resampling uh to fight class imbalance
because there is no PR of class
imbalance it's just a PR of let's say
design of classifier that during a lot
time we just fixed it to 0.5 in cyar but
not only in Cy and everybody was using
this type of things uh and it come just
to like tune this these parameters so
message is tune the parameters of
predictive model I mean this is a given
but what is not given and because it's
not the default is use uh proper scoring
rule so uned probalistic metric like
logos or Bri score and then the the one
that we saw today is at the time that
you want to make your decisions you can
tune using a business a real business
metric and then last message because
this is a free one that's like always
cross validate okay that's super
important okay thanks for your time and
that's my now if you have any questions
I can answer them I'll say that was that
was almost perfect timing right with a
six minutes left for Q&A uh thank you
gilan for that um there are some
questions
um when will the
pr yeah so I can read the first one so
when will the pr uh be accepted so the
pr it just so because we are doing the
release of 1.4 that will arrive in in in
December we might not do the cuts
because we need a bit more review I mean
we are sure that we are going to merge
it so if it's not merged this time it
will be merged in let's say for the next
release which will be June I'm pushing
so that it is going in but uh Christmas
is coming so it's it's complicated um
but it will be either in 1.4 or either
in
1.5 second question is is the new tun sh
classifier model agnostic and I would
say yes uh you can pass the models um
and just it's just that the EJ boost
need to implement the metadata routin
that we are doing iner and we might uh
see with them if we can improve
that and then can cost gain Matrix be
helpful in imbalance cases this is
exactly what I did like inside the last
uh the last examples basically so yeah
this
is so I don't know there's any other
questions I was going to say there might
be some more in chat you are getting a
nice little shout out currently the best
presentation in my opinion love that um
but it looks like antons might have a
quick question as well that we head on
before
now uh wait so I'm looking at the chat
now what about the cases with extreme so
the ex extreme case is exactly the same
I mean it's just that
usually heav you have very large very
large cases it's just coming by when you
come to the decision it's just a matter
of how you are moving uh those things at
the end is you want I mean what machine
learning is trying to do is to optimize
a proper scoring rules and a probability
probalistic
classifier uh
so until that you optimize that then you
are fine and then the decision come
afterwards and is like that's why you
need to optimize with a grid search the
log loss and the Brier score that's the
most important things and then is just
tuning if you try to go in between then
you will not get the right probability
and you will not have something that you
expect the class weights so I see what
about the class weight do they mess up
the calibration it's exactly a
resampling under the hood so it's
messing up the the calibration as
well okay when to use
calibrations uh so you you shouldn't do
uh let's say you should look at the
classifier make a reliability plot if
you see that your classifier is not well
calibrated then you will need to
calibrate it and this is kind of
important let's say when you really want
to use the the the probabilities output
of the
classifier I think I did all of
them there's a few more that yeah in the
Q&A
section yeah yes
so so the question about uh that you can
get a positive number from the C Matrix
because you have a large numbers at the
end of the day your metric is
summarizing this cost Matrix adding
everything together and you try to
maximize it or minimize it uh and at the
end of the day like you try to maximize
the gate gain uh so it doesn't
matter what you try I mean somehow is
that this is linked to what you try to
optimize so I don't see any problem with
that uh but I would be happy like if you
have Conta examples I mean I would be
happy to to see
that
um so the matth core CF um I mean to be
more efficient I'm not really sure so
the thing that the mat Corf is better
than accuracy and all of this in the way
that it it's consuming the full um uh
confusion Matrix statistics but at the
end optimizing this metrix doesn't mean
that you optimize this is not a proper
score inverse so you don't get the best
probability classifier and that's what
is like problematic here and by being
more efficient I would say argue that I
want to see it I want to see with C
validation to not be to be sure that we
are not inside error bars of things okay
so uh somehow I mean I would be I I
would say okay but I need to see why I
mean if there's like what are the
experiment behind
that in a few seconds why not resampling
for class imbalance I mean the only
place that you can still want to
imbalance is uh maybe to speed up you
learning so you might uh want to
resamples fit classifiers and then you
need to recalibrate your classifier but
because you train on less data and maybe
it's good enough then uh you can you can
basically uh still use a resampling for
that specific use case but in general
this is not great if you try to be to
get to calibr classifier so if you
resample you will need to to recalibrate
your classifier and the second thing
that with this resampling you are not
controlling for everything so you are
not controlling for um the best
decisions that you can get at the
end